Você toma melatonina todo dia para
dormir? Acabou de sair um estudo da
American Heart Association que tá
deixando todo mundo de cabelo em pé.
Eles analisaram 130.000 pessoas e
descobriram que quem usou melatonina por
mais de um ano teve 90% mais chance de
desenvolver insuficiência cardíaca. Mas
calma, respira fundo, porque essa
história tem muito mais camadas do que
aparenta. E olha, você que me acompanha
sabe que eu sempre vou além do
sensacionalismo. Eu vou te mostrar o que
que esse estudo realmente significa,
qual é a ciência por trás disso e,
principalmente se você deve ou não deve
jogar o potinho de melatonina que tá na
sua mesa fora. Bom, deixa eu começar te
contando como esse estudo foi feito. Os
pesquisadores pegaram prontuários
eletrônicos de 130.828
adultos com insônia crônica. Metade
deles tinha registros de uso de
melatonina por pelo menos um ano. A
outra metade sem registro nenhum de
melatonina. Acompanharam todo mundo por
5 anos e olharam o que aconteceu. E aí
vem o resultado que viralizou. 90% mais
risco de insuficiência cardíaco no grupo
da melatonina. Além disso, três vezes e
meia mais internações por problemas
cardíacos e quase o dobro de mortes por
qualquer causa. Agora me diz uma coisa,
isso parece assustador, não é? Mas aqui
tá o puro lugar. Esse é um estudo
observacional.
Sabe o que que significa? Eles só
olharam para trás, pegaram dados que já
existiam em computadores e tentaram
achar padrões. Não testaram nada de
verdade, não controlaram variáveis
importantes. É tipo você notar que todo
mundo que vai muito ao hospital acaba
morrendo e concluir que o hospital mata.
Tá vendo o problema? Vamos pensar
juntos. Quem é que usa melatonina todo
santo dia por anos? Geralmente é quem
tem insônia severa, persistente,
crônica. E aqui mora um detalhe crucial
que esse estudo não conseguiu separar
direito. A insônia em si já é um fator
de risco cardiovascular muito bem
estabelecido. Tem dezenas de estudos
mostrando que insônia crônica aumenta a
pressão arterial, aumenta hormônios de
estresse, causa inflamação sistêmica,
mexe com sistema nervosimpático.
Uma metaanálise publicada em 2024 no
Journal of Clinical Sleep Medicine
mostrou que insônia aumenta risco de
doença arterial coronariana em 14%,
de insuficiência cardíaca em 4%, de
hipertensão em 16%. Tudo isso sem
precisar de melatonina nenhuma. Então
fica a pergunta: será que a melatonina
causa o problema ou será que ela é só
uma marca registrada de quem já tá numa
situação mais complicada? Pensa comigo,
se você tem uma insônia tão severa que
precisa tomar melatonina todos os dias
por anos, provavelmente você já tem
outras coisas acontecendo no seu corpo.
Talvez ansiedade crônica, talvez
depressão, talvez a pineia do sono não
diagnosticada, talvez sí metabólica
começando a dar as caras. E tem mais um
problemão metodológico gigante nesse
estudo. Eles só conseguiram identificar
quem usava melatonina através de
prescrições médicas. Mas isso funciona
bem no Reino Unido, onde melatonina
precisa de receita. Mais nos Estados
Unidos, que compõe uma grande parte dos
dados, melatonina é vendida livremente.
Você sabe disso. Então tem um monte de
gente no grupo Controle que
provavelmente tomava melatonina comprada
na farmácia, mas foi classificada como
não usuária. Isso bagunça completamente
os resultados. Agora vem a parte que eu
quero que você preste muito atenção.
Esse estudo contradiz frontalmente
décadas de pesquisa sobre melatonina e
saúde cardiovascular. Eu vou te dar
alguns exemplos concretos. Um estudo
publicado no Journal of Pineal Research
em 2023 mostrou que melatonina inibe
progressão da aterosclerose através de
redução da galectina 3, aumentando a
tofagia e diminuindo inflamação. Outro
trabalho de 2024 da NPJ biológico Timing
and Sleep demonstrou que melatonina
diminui a hipertensão noturna, melhora a
pressão sistólica e diastólica, reduz a
agregação plaquetária, tem até evidência
que melatonina protege contra lesão de
isquemia, reperfusão no coração, sem
falar do uso da melatonina em altas
doses pro câncer, né? Então, como é que
a gente reconcilia isso? Como é que a
gente pode entender esses dados? Como é
que a mesma substância pode ser
protetora cardiovascular em uns estudos
e aparecer associado a risco em outro? A
resposta mais provável é que não é a
melatonina em si que é o problema que tá
causando isso. O que esse estudo tá
capturando é uma associação, não uma
causa. As pessoas que precisam de
melatonina por tanto tempo já estão em
uma trajetória de risco cardiovascular
aumentado por causa da insônia severa e
provavelmente de outros fatores que nem
foram medidos. Aliás, falando nisso,
esse estudo tem várias limitações que os
próprios autores reconheceram. Eles não
tinham informação sobre gravidade da
insônia, não tinham dados sobre
transtornos psiquiátricos como ansiedade
e depressão. São super comuns e quem tem
insônia crônica, que também aumenta o
risco cardiovascular, não tinham
informação sobre dosagem, sobre
qualidade do sono, mesmo usando
melatonina, sobre outros medicamentos
que a pessoa tomava. E mais importante,
não tinham como saber se a pessoa
realmente tomava melatonina ou se pegou
a receita e deixou guardada na gaveta.
Eu, na minha experiência de muitos anos
passando tratamentos naturais paraa
insônia, eu percebo claramente que a a
melatonina isoladamente é muito difícil
ela resolver insônia. Eu associo ela a
várias outras estratégias. Pera aí,
então, deixa eu te contar uma coisa que
pouquíssima gente tá falando. Sabe qual
a ironia dessa história toda?
Betabloqueadores, que são remédios
fundamentais no tratamento de eficiência
cardíaca, podem causar insônia porque
bloqueiam a produção natural de
melatonina pelo corpo. Então você tem
pessoas com problemas cardíacos tomando
betabloqueadores, desenvolvendo insônia
por causa do remédio, aí tomam
melatonina para tentar dormir e depois
aparece nas estatísticas como usuários
de melatonina com insuficiência
cardíaca. Consegue ver o nó que isso
vira? Agora vamos falar do elefante na
sala. Esse estudo ainda não passou por
revisão por pares. O famoso peer review
foi apresentado como resumo em
congresso, o que significa que os dados
são preliminares, não tem publicação em
revista científica ainda. Isso não
invalida os achados por si, mas
significa
que a gente precisa ter cautela antes de
tomar decisões drásticas baseadas nisso.
E tem outra coisa importante, os números
absolutos do estudo mostram que 4,6% das
pessoas do grupo melatonina
desenvolveram insuficiência cardíaca
comparado com 2,7%
no grupo controle. Sim, estatisticamente
isso dá 90% de aumento no risco
relativo. Olha aí o conceito de risco
relativo. Mas olha só, a diferença
absoluta é menos 2%.
Isso significa que em cada 100 pessoas
usando melatonina, menos de duas
desenvolveram insuficiência cardíaca a
mais do que no grupo controle. Bem
diferente da impressão que o título dá,
né? Tomem muito cuidado com o risco
relativo. Então o que que a gente faz
com tudo isso? Primeiro vamos colocar as
coisas em perspectiva. Se você toma
melatonina ocasionalmente,
por exemplo, para jet ou para ajustar o
seu relógio biológico depois de virar a
noite estudando, relaxa, isso não vai
dar problema nenhum. Esse estudo não tem
nada a ver com você. O problema
potencial aparece com uso crônico, uso
diário por mais de um ano. Segundo
ponto, melatonina não deveria ser a
primeira linha de tratamento para
insônia crônica mesmo. Acabei de falar
disso agora. A abordagem funcional
enxerga insônia como sintoma, não como
doença. Você precisa investigar o que tá
por trás. Pode ser deficiência de
magnésio, pode ser excesso de luz azul à
noite, mexendo com o seu ritmo
cicadiano, pode ser cortisol
desregulado, pode ser pneia do sono,
pode ser ansiedade não tratada, pode ser
microbioma intestinal desbalanceado,
afetando a produção de serotonina e
melatonina do corpo, ou seja, endógena.
Terceiro, se você já toma melatonina faz
tempo, esse estudo não prova que você
deve parar imediatamente, mas serve como
lembrete para investigar porque você
precisa dela. A insônia crônica em si
aumenta risco cardiovascular, então você
deveria estar fazendo uma avaliação mais
ampla de saúde cardiovascular. De
qualquer forma, chega a pressão
arterial, perfil lipídico, glicemia,
inflamação e função endotelial. E olha,
tem um detalhe técnico fascinante aqui.
A dose fisiológica de melatonina é
minúscula na faixa de 03 a 05 mg, mas a
maioria dos suplementos vem com 3, 5 e
até 10 mg. Para câncer tudo bem, mas
para insônia não é uma boa. Isso é 10 a
30 vezes mais que o seu corpo produz
naturalmente. E diferente do que
acontece com a melatonina hidrógena, que
tem liberação pulsátil coordenada com o
ritmo cicadiano, quando você toma o
suplemento, você tá jogando uma dose
farmacológica de uma vez só. Isso pode
dessincronizar receptores de melatonina
a longo prazo. E outro aspecto que
merece atenção, melatonina nos Estados
Unidos é suplemento e não é regulado.
Isso tudo já mostraram que o que tá no
rótulo muitas vezes não corresponde ao
que tá no frasco. Pode ter desde 83%
menos até 478%
mais melatonina do que o declarado.
Alguns produtos tinham contaminação com
serotonina, então parte dos efeitos
adversos pode nem ser da melatonina em
si, mas da qualidade duvidosa dos
produtos. Agora, deixa te dar uma visão
mais ampla. A literatura científica
sobre melatonina e sistema
cardiovascular é complexa, tem
evidências sólidas de que melatonina tem
propriedades antioxidantes potentes,
protege mitocôndrias cardíacas, reduz
estresse oxidativo, modula inflamação,
mas também tem evidências de que os
receptores de melatonina t funções
complexas no sistema cardiovascular, que
a gente ainda nem entende direito, não
entende completamente. Pode ser que o
uso crônico de doses altas afete esses
receptores de formas que ainda não
mapeamos direito. Uma coisa que me deixa
pensativa é que esse achado pode estar
nos mostrando marcador de risco e não
causador de risco. Ou seja, precisar de
melatonina todo dia por anos pode ser
sinal de que algo mais profundo tá
acontecendo no seu organismo. É parecido
com aquela história de que febre não
causa doença, mas é sinal de que tem
doença rolando. A melatonina crônica
pode ser sinal de disupção cicardiana
severa, que por si só é um fator de
risco cardiovascular independente. Do
ponto de vista da abordagem funcional, o
que que isso nos ensina? Que a gente
precisa ir além do sintoma. Se você não
dorme, em vez de só tomar melatonina ou
qualquer outro remédio, rivolt
eternamente, investigue o que tá
impedindo o seu corpo de produzir
melatonina naturalmente na hora certa.
Olha a sua exposição à luz durante o
dia, a sua exposição à luz à noite, teus
níveis de magnésio, teu eixo HPA,
hipotálapito anal, tua saúde intestinal,
teu equilíbrio de neurotransmissores. E
tem estratégias que podem potencializar
a melatonina endógena sem precisar de
suplemento. Por exemplo, exposição à luz
solar pela manhã sincroniza o teu
relógio biológico. Evitar luz azul à
noite permite que tua glândula pineal
produza melatonina naturalmente. Manter
horários regulares de sono, treina o seu
ritmo cicadiano.
Temperatura ambiente mais fria no quarto
facilita a queda de temperatura corporal
que dispara o sono. Magnésio antes de
dormir ativa receptores gaba e melhora a
qualidade de sono sem interferir na
melatonina. Agora, tem casos em que
melatonina pode fazer sentido a longo
prazo. Alguns transtornos de ritmo
cicadiano, trabalho de turnos, turnos
noturnos, obviamente, cegueira, mas
mesmo nesses casos, a dose deveria ser
fisiológica e não farmacológica e
deveria vir junto com a avaliação
periódica de saúde cardiovascular, já
que essas condições por si só aumentam o
risco cardíaco. E eu vou te falar uma
verdade inconveniente, esse estudo não
vai mudar nada na prática médico
convencional no curto prazo, porque
melatonina não é medicamento controlado
nos Estados Unidos. As pessoas vão
continuar comprando e usando, mas ele
acende um sinal amarelo importante.
Precisamos de estudos randomizados,
controlados de longo prazo, avaliando
segurança cardiovascular de melatonina
crônica. Precisamos entender melhor os
mecanismos. Precisamos saber se existe
dose segura, se existe tempo limite de
uso, se existe perfil de paciente que
tem mais risco. Por enquanto, a minha
recomendação baseada em tudo que a gente
sabe seria: use melatonina para o que
ela foi feita, realinhamento cicadiano
temporário, não como muleta eterna pra
insônia crônica. Se você precisa de
melatonina todo santo dia por meses, o
problema não é só que você não consegue
dormir. O problema é que algo no seu
organismo tá desregulado e merece
investigação mais profunda. Vamos tratar
a causa raiz e não só o sintoma. E mais
uma coisa, se você tem histórico
familiar de doença cardiovascular, se
você já tem fatores de risco como
hipertensão ao diabetes, se você tá
acima dos 50 anos e precisa usar
melatonina cronicamente, conversa com o
teu médico ou médica sobre monitoramento
cardiovascular mais próximo. Não precisa
entrar em pânico, mas precisa estar
atento. Esse estudo não prova que
melatonina causa insuficiência cardíaca,
mas ele mostra uma associação que merece
ser levada a sério, merece investigada
mais a fundo. E quanto a ciência não nos
dá respostas definitivas, o caminho mais
sensato é usar melatonina com
passimônia, com cuidado, com bom senso e
focar em corrigir os problemas de base
que estão atrapalhando o seu sono.
Estresse, meu amigo, sempre o estresse.
Saia do vídeo agora se você gosta de
ficar no superficial. Eu vou te contar
uma verdade conveniente. O YouTube e o
Conselho de Medicina me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens e
omitir protocolos controversos. E na
comunidade fechada de membros não existe
filtro. Eu compartilho os exatos
protocolos que eu uso na minha clínica,
casos de reversão que parecem possíveis,
combinações of label que funcionam além
de fornecedores confiáveis,
interpretação avançada de exames. E
temos agora novidade, o nível dois de
acesso que você tem além da liv
semanais, tem as lives para discutir os
artigos científicos de ponta. Então nós
temos lives semanais respondendo
perguntas, lives a cada duas semanas
para discutir artigos pro nível dois.
PDF com 47 protocolos exclusivos e grupo
no WhatsApp para trocar ideia. Se você
quer a visão funcional real, sem
simplificação para as massas, clique em
seja membro. Não é para curiosos, é para
quem quer resultados. M.